- Diane, it's 9:15 a.m.
The donuts are fresh and the sun shining
which means, as locals
like to say around here,
“I’m as happy as a clam at
high-water on a Sunday.”
This morning, I woke up to a curious note
under my bedroom door.
It read, “The fat man who tore
down the wall wants to know…”
Wants to know what?
And who is the fat man?
Let's investigate.
Diane, we're once again
struck by the realization that
all of us on this planet Earth
only understand a fraction
of what's going on around us.
That's why I'm employing a
unique investigative strategy
that relies both on ancient
Tibetan practices and intuition.
Chance will be our guide.
I'll read the name and
then I'll throw the rock.
Mark Frost, TV writer.
Miss.
David Lynch, director.
Ugh.
Brad Dukes, author.
(whoosh)
(glass breaking)
Let's call up Brad Dukes
who wrote this book,
Reflections, An Oral
History of Twin Peaks.
Operator, get me Brad Dukes.
Brad, can you hear me?
No time for pleasantries, Brad.
I received a note under my door.
It read The fat man who tore
down the wall wants to know...
What does he want to know?
It was Bob's spirit in
Millen's body, we know.
The fat man wants to
know who killed Laura?
Thanks, Brad.
Operator, give me Jules
Haimovitz, TV exec.
Jules, I received a note this morning
whose contents you might
have the key to deciphering.
It read, “The fat man who tore
down the wall wants to know…”
I believe it's in reference to Laura.
V. Gorbachev?
Aaron Spelling, the TV exec.
(mysterious music)
Gorbachev, the eighth and final
leader of the Soviet Union?
What did he want to know?
Thanks, Jules.
Actually by now,
the fat man who tore down
the wall knows the answer.